One of Hollywood's dystopian dramas has been
affected by a real-life pandemic.
A Quiet Place Part 2, the long-awaited sequel
to director John Krasinski's hugely successful
horror debut, has been delayed due to growing
concerns over the COVID-19 outbreak sweeping
the globe.
"What is going on?"
This news comes to us courtesy of the director
himself, who confirmed on social media that
the second film in the Quiet Place universe
- a dystopian world in which monsters attack
anyone who makes the slightest sound - will
be delayed from its international March 18th
opening.
Beyond that worldwide release, the flick was
also slated for a March 19th release in the
United Kingdom and a March 20th opening in
North America.
Plenty of films have seen their release dates
delayed, their production halted or suspended,
or their normal journey to theaters otherwise
disrupted by COVID-19, a mutation of the coronavirus
that has proven lethal to more vulnerable
portions of the population and which has a
higher rate of serious cases than the seasonal
flu.
However, in the wake of countries like Italy
pushing its citizens to enter a state of quarantine
which prohibits its citizens from attending
public gatherings or spending time in crowded
places, as well as outbreaks within the United
States, the entertainment industry is paying
attention.
The plot of A Quiet Place Part 2 finds Evelyn,
played by Krasinski's real-life wife Emily
Blunt, trying to survive with her children
in the aftermath of her husband's death in
the first film.
Delayed at seemingly the last minute, a new
release date for the movie was not immediately
announced.
Paramount Pictures, the studio behind the
Quiet Place sequel, released a statement about
the film's delay:
"After much consideration, and in light of
the ongoing and developing situation concerning
coronavirus and restrictions on global travel
and public gatherings, Paramount Pictures
will be moving the worldwide release of A
Quiet Place Part II.
We believe in and support the theatrical experience,
and we look forward to bringing this film
to audiences this year once we have a better
understanding of the impact of this pandemic
on the global theatrical marketplace."
Krasinski is back in the director's chair
for the second installment, and he also appears
in the narrative as his character Lee in flashbacks.
In his statement about the film's delay on
Instagram, he kept things positive, writing,
"One of the things I'm most proud of is that
people have said our movie is one you have
to see all together.
Well due to the ever-changing circumstances
of what's going on in the world around us,
now is clearly not the right time to do that.
As insanely excited as we are for all of you
to see this movie...
I'm gonna wait to release the film till we
CAN all see it together!
So here's to our group movie date!
See you soon!"
It's safe to assume that the team behind A
Quiet Place Part II didn't want to take such
a drastic measure when it came to the film's
release, but with concerns over public safety
hitting a frightening high, it does seem like
they made the responsible choice.
“There are people out there.
People worth saving."
As the outbreak of COVID-19 continues across
the world, the United States is entering a
potential state of emergency, while other
countries are finding themselves on various
forms of lockdown to prevent any further,
potentially fatal spread.
Unsurprisingly, the film industry has been
hit hard, with tons of films facing filming
delays and halted releases.
The newest James Bond film, No Time to Die,
was one of the first films to have its release
date affected by the crisis.
As COVID-19 spread, Daniel Craig's final outing
as 007 was delayed by a whopping eight months,
getting a new November release date instead
of its original April premiere.
As the United States faced its own emerging
COVID-19 cases when the virus spread outside
of Europe and Asia, new concerns grew, affecting
a number of other projects as well.
Between filming delays on the next Mission:
Impossible movie, a temporary hold on production
on The CW's Riverdale, and the next Fast & Furious
film getting delayed for an entire year, studios
are sparing no effort to keep people safe
as the pandemic sets in.
Stay safe out there - we hope to see you at
the movies when this all blows over.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.